Okay, so we get this diagram.
containing
set a
set B
which have 65 elements and 10 elements respectively.
And you have 25 elements that are not
even in these sets. They're outside of the set.
So if I can say that again, we have 100 elements.
in the Universal set so this
Let this rectangle this white figure.
represent all 100 elements
in this Universal set 65 of
those elements will go into set a 10 of
those elements will go into set B and the remaining 25 will live
outside of a and b
this space here in the Middle with the number five minute.
I've kind of made it.
Great this time.
because this is the
because this is the intersection of A and B.
So five from a go in here and five
from B.
going there
so if you were to
remove the set from the figure.
It would have all the 60 elements B would have only
five elements.
Okay.
Now, let me tell you about the cardinality.
This is simple concept cardinality is the size.
Of a set how many elements we have in a set mathematically we
express this with two vertical bars as you can see
here. So the cardinality of U is 100.
Cardinality of a 65 and then for B is
10.
Okay.
So there's another 25 which live outside of a and b.
So here we have the
table
containing the marginal frequency
and the joint frequency
By frequency we mean count.
By module, we mean how much a set has on its
own and by joint obviously.
We'll talk about the union of those two sets.
So
set a and b
have five elements and cut in common.
Now the way you want to read this table.
Is First Column wise?
column wise has to do with set a so our focus
is set a
in the second column we have what we call the complement of a that
till they symbol that is complement complement means
that which is not in set a
so the columns have to do with say the rows obviously set
B.
So again A and B.
Have five elements in common.
a and not b
We have 60 elements y60 elements.
Set a has 65 but five of those.
Are shared with set B.
We want the number of elements that are unique to
set a
So that's 60.
And of course if we add up these two numbers we get
the original 65.
So irrespective of whether a shares those elements or
not 65 is the total frequency.
That is the cardinality of the set.
And you can see it's the same for set B.
B has five elements in common with a
but if we would take set B, excluding the
elements that it hasn't common with set a
would get 5 again add does to get add up these
two sums.
We get 10 again. That's the original frequency of set B.
Now let's talk about the complements.
Not a not b
it gives us 30.
Why is that the case? Well, let's see. Well
as the 5 in here plus the 25 out here.
Just before I show you why that is the case. Just notice that
when we do sum up.
the frequencies in the margins of this table
We get a hundred so 10 plus 9 gives us 165
plus 35 gives us a hundred. We're going
to talk about marginal probability.
In a moment.
Just so you know, this is where that would comes from.
the margins of the table so four Bayesian
probability when we are counting the odds and the
likelihood
the odds will involve the marginal probabilities.
the likelihood the conditional probabilities
the numbers we will get for these terms will come from a table that looks
like this.
So we will literally get those numbers from the margins, but let's
carry on.
Let me first make the case for the compliment.
The intersection the intersection of the complement of
a and complement of B.